oh
nice
sorry i'm just trying to think what i
did while he goes yeah
what did you do
what would you get up to yeah what'd you
do ah [ __ ] what did i do
i saw my family here first time in two
years because like we all finally got uh
vaccinated because we we all made a rule
we were like we're not going to see each
other until we're all fully vaccinated
because my cousin's like my younger
cousin's only like three years old or
something so i was like god forbid i
didn't want to give him code right yeah
my family so we finally got vaccinated
it's so weird because the last time i
saw my cousin he's five now and he was
like two last time i saw him so it's
just weird i was like i'm having a
conversation with this kid oh my god
yeah it's it's it's so crazy fast how
like kids grow up yeah like it's just
like oh it's a completely different
person we've reached that age now it is
yeah we really like we've and like i had
a lot of uh like friends living here
from since i've known in like high
school in uni who were like i haven't
seen you in a while like you know now
that once the country opens up we should
like catch up
oh but i have to be a weekend because i
have to take care of my two kids i'm
just like
have we really gotten to that stage now
i've really gotten to that age because
like
it was just my birthday like about a
week ago um and i was like it's it's
time to get to that point i mean you can
relate god because you're older than me
but like i feel it's around you're a
boomer yeah
but like i feel i don't know at least to
me like around 27 is because i just
turned 27 yeah it's get it starts to get
to the point where it's not so much like
oh yeah it's my birthday it's more like
oh it's my birthday yeah
i've been like that for a while yeah
yeah yeah it's 8 15. yeah it's it's not
like it's not you know there's no like
just that kind of like childish
excitement of like getting older anymore
it slowly starts to turn into that oh
god i'm getting older yeah stage you
know
are you i guess yeah does it happen when
you get 30 is that when that happens um
i don't know like for me
here i remember like it didn't didn't
really hit me until i was uh 29 i guess
and so like ev every every year uh so
every year like we uh we
when when i lived in england we had like
this massive like party where we get to
catch up with all of our friends in
england so we'd like so we have this
party every year yeah um and i remember
it truly hit me because we were at this
party uh and we're there for a few days
so i was having a shower in the morning
and then
i kind of it kind of just hit me that
this is the last time i'm going to have
this catch up
before i'm 30 in my 20s and then i just
had this like full-on [ __ ]
existential crisis in the shower well
like i mean i take long showers i i i
take long showers anyway but like it was
just me
that day that was a long shower
that was like even for me that was a
long [ __ ] shower i think i think
sydney like thought i got kidnapped or
something you know like i was just
standing there just like
oh my god
like i didn't know how to process that
and it was just
it was just like i think i took like an
hour long shower and then [ __ ] hell
but your hands must have been sponged oh
yeah they were they were the whole body
was spongy and then like off that shower
which is completely fine
i washed my sins away i was ready for my
30s afterwards um i also knew that i was
like getting to that point because i uh
me and like a bunch of my friends who
were all vaccinated so safe but uh we we
rented out this like log cabin yeah like
the mountains in chiba and it was like
really nice because you know i hadn't
really had it like a nightlife for about
a month since everything was like closed
down it was like there's no point going
out to like restaurants or anything like
that at night so it's finally nice to
actually you know [ __ ] get out and
yeah change of environment stuff like
that especially with your friends and i
knew i was also getting to that point
because uh all i received was some
pieces of clothing two bottles of wine
and a bottle of whiskey
and i'm like oh i'm getting to the point
where like i see a bottle of whiskey and
i'm like pogchamp
just cause like after a certain age you
normally have everything you want yeah
right i mean like anything i'd want is
like yeah you want to buy me a porsche i
don't know yeah no
it's just it's just like a gift that a
mate doesn't already have it's either
like in in an acceptable price range
just doesn't really exist it just gets
bigger and bigger it's either like you
buy you you buy them like a new job or a
new car or a new house well what do you
want you know
[Laughter]
but uh
yeah i mean like i'd say another thing
that happened to me in the uk and that
you've just reminded me of is
i i went to the uh went to the tescos to
uh get my bottle of wine then they asked
me how old i was i never get id'd ever
and then
i was just like oh i'm 20
no wait
i had a moment like that too and someone
asked me how old i was like 23 oh [ __ ]
yeah i legitimately forgot at one point
how old i was turning i was like am i
turning 27 or 28. yeah [ __ ] i don't
remember i had to like do math in my
head to figure out not like how old i
was yeah like i i'd literally like
forgotten that i had turned 30 because
like i had not been asked for id since i
turned 30. yeah and uh so so yeah i like
by like muscle memory i just started
saying 20 something and then like had
like this darren brown moment where i
just forgot the number and i was like
vsauce music plays oh no i'm i'm 32. and
they were like
we see some id
and i was like oh my god i get to show
my id again oh my god i never get id i
wish i got a dude really yeah because i
didn't get id here
um in japan for some reason i started
getting id'd again when i went back to
the uk i think i think i look older than
you sometimes i think what do you mean
sometimes sometimes sometimes i think
most days i think i think most people
who watch who tune in to trash days for
the first time is like wait god's the
oldest one everyone is always thinks
that i'm older than i am yeah which is
fair enough yeah just means and everyone
thinks god's like 20 years i'm [ __ ]
miserable that's right
i'm always complaining i can't wait till
i'm 50. i'm going to complain about
everything it's the beard man it's the
beard no no you have a good beard too
yeah but the thing is if i shave this
off i look 17. well i look like a child
like there's plenty of trash days
episodes where i don't have a beard
right and i i i look at it i'm like whoa
yeah yeah it's just like you shave your
beard and instantly you just like lose
five years
like 10 i think i think maybe you turned
like a 12 year old
whereas i feel if god came to a trash
taste recording with a beard like ours
he'd look like a [ __ ] like
i've had like a five o'clock shadow
before and yeah yeah i don't know how
that looks
i don't know i just don't like it when
our beard's too long you just don't know
man just just feels like yours
you could you could kill it or you could
kill it how can you kill it maybe i'll
try one day yeah one one one randomly
maybe my mid thirties is this the time
you could have grown one while you were
away and then come back come back
what's up guys
i've assimilated
you your voice is dropped
next time we have like like a break when
we don't record trash taste i'll just
let my beard grow out and it'll just be
like
like the dichotomy of like one trash
taste episodes for the for the audience
to be like
what happened during this week
wow girl really aged during this week
didn't he
god just like does some doctor strange
[ __ ] skips time or some nonsense or
something like that oh my god
i feel like a beard could weirdly suit
you
i know um i i'm just not a big fan of
beards on me personally i don't know
it's i i also like
this there's this like patch where a
beard like can't grow on my on my chin
as well so i don't know how weird that
would look if i grow it out i have a bit
of patchwork as well around the place
because like the reason the reason i
have this patch is because as a kid uh
when i was a kid i got uh well it's not
that big of an exciting story but my
chin got cut open
uh because i
was on the playground fell on
uh hit a kid fell on the floor and then
my chin splits oh [ __ ] my chin open
uh once that got closed up there's just
this patch on my chin that just won't
grow hair so i've always found it like a
sticker just stick something just grab
something just take something we'll just
just grow it out and just like kind of
bundle it
yeah braid it
braided into the middle so it just comes
down